um can we start if possible with with
france and uh president macron's uh
re-election has there been a collective
sigh of relief briefed in whitehall at
this uh this news well the uk government
is always ready to work with governments
of other countries once they're elected
we obviously congratulate president
macron on his victory
and look forward to you know working
closely with him i think the situation
in russia ukraine and elsewhere in the
world i think where there are you know
dangerous and uncertain forces at work
demonstrates the importance
of european democracies and free
countries around the world uh working
closely together and i think you know we
look forward to doing that with
president macron as he forms his new
administration i i think however there
will be a number of people in europe
this side of the channel and on the
other somewhat concerned about marine le
pen and the strength of the polling that
she enjoyed yep she has made her kind of
brand of far-right politics somewhat
more palatable but the two in five of
those who went to the polls in the
french presidential election voted for
her must be of some concern
well i think across western democracies
it's important that leaders listen i
think
electorates across the western world in
america across europe
have concerns about issues like cost of
living like immigration and it's
important that elected governments
uh listen to those concerns and respond
to them um and that applies you know in
many different countries and but as i
say look as far as the french election
is concerned you know we're looking
forward to working with president macron
uh to to meet the global challenges that
we uh as free western countries face
together
for once in all of our chats let's
actually talk about something on your
brief shall we and the government now
moving forward with the tracy crouch
review putting fans at the center of
football once again just tell us just a
little bit more about it yeah well the
government committed in its 2019
election manifesto to have a fan-led
review that was set up about a year ago
and it was led by tracy crouch a
conservative mp and former sport
minister she spoke to i think hundreds
possibly even thousands of fans uh up
and down the country she made a number
of recommendations
she had 10 strategic recommendations
which we're accepting but important
amongst those was the idea that we need
to have a statutory football regulator
so a regulator set up in law by an act
of parliament because football clubs are
critical parts of our local community
i'm a member of parliament in croydon in
south london crystal palace is our local
club and it is a really important part
of our local community i went to my
first game there with my dad in
1991. um i'm taking my i've took my son
to the semi-final um a week or two ago
which unfortunately we lost i wasn't
uh the home game against watford at
seller spark in a couple of weeks so
it's something which i think you know um
by you know it's intergenerational right
families do this together it's part of a
local community
so when a club goes bankrupt and and
potentially disappears
barry and mackelsfield have done
derby county obviously in all kinds of
difficulties at the moment and other
clubs have come very close that is
something which really
affects the heart of communities it
makes a football club different to a
normal business and that's why this
regulator statutory regulator will make
sure that football clubs are in a
financially healthy position
and owners don't get into the position
where they kind of gamble recklessly
with the club's financial future by
spending way way too much more than they
can afford and putting the club's future
into jeopardy has happened in those
cases that i just mentioned i think a
number of people that we will be very
intrigued by by the owners and the
owners and directors test that is also
going to be brought in i mean it's a
very topical issue we all know that the
sale of chelsea is going through at the
moment can we just be clear would that
apply retrospectively to whoever takes
over at chelsea fc well the so the
intention behind the new uh test which
would be administered by the regulator
rather than by the football authorities
as at the moment as a transfer of
responsibility for doing that test would
apply not just at the
point of takeover but it would also
apply um from time to time on an ongoing
basis as as well the details are going
to be set out by my colleague the sport
minister
in parliament uh later on today but it
will be an ongoing test not a one-time
test and it will it'll be wider than the
current one so look at questions of
integrity uh financial resources
capability and capacity those kind of
questions to make sure that people who
are taking on custodianship
of such an important cultural asset like
a like a football club uh the people are
gonna that are gonna handle it properly
can we talk about the political story of
the weekend and it of course involves
angela raynor and that article in the
mail on sunday when you read what was
written by the mail on sunday's
political editor what was your response
i was appalled i was appalled that um
that sentiment was being expressed it's
offensive uh it's misogynistic the prime
minister and cabinet ministers have been
absolutely right to roundly condemn that
sentiment and to offer support to angela
uh rayner on this issue i've never heard
anyone
say anything like that or even hinted it
and if i did i would be disgusted and
appalled nobody should have to
suffer the kind of misogynistic um abuse
which that sentiment amounts to can i
can i take it from from what you said
then that the whips will be finding out
who said it and disciplining them
accordingly
well i think if it ever comes out who
said that then i imagine they would be
subject to discipline now yeah but the
reason i ask is that as things stand we
have had a couple of tweets sent by the
prime minister we understand that a
whatsapp message was sent but you know
there is a story of course in all of
this the story is that five of your
colleagues or a number of your
colleagues chose to brief against an
incredibly senior female labour
politician
in some of the most as you yourself say
misogynistic terms so again i'll ask
does this not demand an internal
investigation
by the whips by by the party
well i think they'll be looking at
whether they know who said this i've got
no idea who said it and i say no one has
ever said anything like that to me or
even hinted at it and i think everybody
is appalled by um by the misogynistic
sentiment i think we all need to keep
the
tone of discourse in public life uh kind
of civil and respectful and focus on the
issues that our constituents expect us
to deal with not engage in this kind of
of of what essentially is abuse
the reason i ask if there is more to be
done is to be fair at the weekend the
kind of conservative party's commitment
to to
sorting this mess out didn't really
appear terribly strong i want to show
our viewers um that which the the prime
minister tweeted uh in response to the
article and you know when you read the
words that they are pretty strong as
much as i disagree with angela raynor on
almost every political issue i respect
her as a parliamentarian and just
deplore the misogyny directed at her
anonymously today very very strong you
would say and then we saw this
from the dean doris as much as i
disagree with black the exact same tweet
what's going on here
well i mean they share the same view
their colleagues and governments they
share the same view to the word yeah i
mean look i mean dean doran nadine is my
boss and she feels very strongly about
um the place of women in politics and
that this sort of abuse is unacceptable
i'm sure she'll have disgusted with the
prime minister um they'll have reached
the same view and they've used the same
words there's nothing surprising that
two colleagues in government have
exactly the same view and use the same
words there is nothing surprising about
two human beings sitting down at a
keyboard and tapping out exactly the
same sentence construction they've got
the same view on this issue
honestly you're trying to maintain that
the cultural secretary didn't copy and
paste this well it wasn't something that
was sent to her these aren't her own
words they're clearly not their own
words because they were said by the
prime minister 15 minutes look i mean
i've heard dean talk about this kind of
issue in private quite a lot and i can
tell you the sentiments being expressed
there are sentiments i've heard her
express countless times over the over
the last uh nine months that i've i've
worked with her so it doesn't surprise
me
at all that she's expressing herself so
strongly but nor does it surprise me
that she and the prime minister are
saying exactly the same thing
if they were saying different things
you'd be asking me about that wouldn't
you i would but i wouldn't be asking you
about this if she'd use slightly
different words you know it is clearly
not her own thoughts but she may think
that but she's chosen to copy it
directly from the prime minister the
reason i ask is of course we are in an
election cycle an election cycle which
looks like it could be
is it fair to say these local elections
could be pretty challenging for the
conservatives well i think local
elections mid-term tend to be
challenging for for any government um
where you know both colours is if you
look back over the history of the last
20 or 30 years midterm local elections
always uh always pose challenges and
very often they also reflect local
conditions so again we've got local
elections in croydon the borough that i
represent uh the labour council there
has gone bankrupt because the first
london bar to go bankrupt in 25 years
because they engaged in reckless
property speculation they bought a hotel
that then went bust those sort of local
issues i think do play a very important
role as well but the national issues
clearly play a part in all of this as
well i mean we're reading stevens
winford in the times this morning at
quoting a senior official who's seen the
sue grey report who says it is so
damning that the prime minister should
the prime minister may go as a result i
mean you know conservatives are pretty
happy that sue gray isn't reporting this
side of the election
well i'm not going to speculate about
what this report may or may not say well
obviously i'm sure debate it very amply
when it gets when it gets published um
but as i say we're talking to i've been
out on about croydon this weekend
all day yesterday for example and people
are focused rightly on local issues
we're electing local councils to run
local authorities and the issues people
are focusing on are who you know which
party who is best to run your local
council in the case of croydon the
appalling bankrupt uh labour
administration i you know i think
deserves to be voted out and i hope they
will be but it's not just it's not just
the electorate that perhaps are going to
give the conservatives a bit of a
kicking at the moment i mean last week i
mean the government tried to delay the
investigation the privileges committee
investigation i mean were you given a
call by by the chief whip i mean did the
chief whip say to you that he wanted you
to vote to delay that i mean what was
your response to that well i think there
was obviously a bit of a debate that
went on about whether the debate was
over whether the vote it's all a bit
technical over whether the vote to refer
to the privilege committee should have
should have happened last week whether
the vote should have happened after the
police investigations and the sugar
report had concluded that was the debate
it's a rather uh technical nuanced
debate
technical on the one hand you had the
government wanting the amendment putting
forward an amendment you know to delay
to delay the investigation which they
then pulled half an hour before the vote
yeah well it was the debate about when
to have the vote and they decided that
since the prime minister felt he had
nothing to hide and doesn't mind even
more scrutiny this will be by the way
the third investigation you've got the
police one the two grey one now this one
is the third one uh he said he had
nothing to hide and therefore
doesn't mind parliament uh performing
whatever scrutiny that it wants to so
they just got on with it and had the
vote last thursday which as it turned
out was and it wasn't a vote at all it
was completely uncontested and not a
single person voted against it so it
turned out to be um a non uh a
non-controversy chris phil good to have
you in the studio this morning thanks
for joining thank you